[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport sur TV 78 l'émission ne
surtout pas manqué si vous êtes un
amoureux de sport local aujourd'hui pour
la dernière émission de la saison il y
aura comme toujours des analyses
techniques des décryptages et surtout
une dose de bonne humeur pour ma
compagnie le chroniqueur sont avec nous
sur ce plateau ils sont en pleine forme
pour l'été et certains commencent même à
bronzer présentation en musique on
commence à ma droite musique c'est un
véritable rayon de soleil dans cette
émission elle nous vient tout droit de
Poissy elle aime tous les sports et en
particulier le basket et la course à
pied elle est adepte des distances
longues à la notamment participé au half
Marathon des Sables Audrey Lepère est
avec nous pendant une heure la pisse à
case
bon bah bonjour Michael bonjour à toute
l'équipe la dernière mais c'est je pense
que le meilleur pour la fin comme on dit
donc évidemment le soleil est là le
sport est là la bonne humeur est là
tout au long de l'été donc vous allez
profiter de Audrey et des autres
chroniqueurs tout au long de l'été on
continue à gauche musique vous
reconnaissez cette musique c'est un
monument dans cette émission lui n'est
pas en vacances il a charbonner pendant
plusieurs jours pour préparer cette
émission comme d'habitude il est
spécialiste du sport italien mais c'est
également une encyclopédie sur le sport
evinois notre Italian lover Grégory
canalet est avec nous pendant une heure
bonjour Michel bonjour Audrey bonjour à
tous Comment allez-vous Grégory très
bien je suis très heureux de vous
retrouver merci de m'avoir vous supplier
pendant deux émissions merci à vous
c'est une belle expérience j'ai regardé
les émissions vous avez aimé j'ai aimé
mais je suis très heureux de retrouver
mon rôle de chroniqueur et de retrouver
ma ton désirée envolée voilà que je vais
pouvoir vous distiller tout à l'heure on
l'attend avec impatience comme à chaque
fois on passe de l'autre côté musique ce
n'est plus un petit nouveau dans cette
émission il est devenu au fil du temps
un titulaire indiscutable il crée sa
légende à chaque émission et les
responsables sponsoring chez Orange en
Île-de-France
dans le sport il est amoureux du sport
mesdames et messieurs Philippe bolak est
avec nous pendant une heure bonjour à
tous bonjour Audrey comment allez-vous
très bien impeccable les vacances se
sont prochaines donc la guerre d'eder là
pour avant les avant l'été
l'après-midi toute la journée au
Seigneur Marcoussis donc voilà il
faisait très très chaud faisait chaud
mais ça bosse quand même encore ça bosse
un petit peu on termine de l'autre côté
musique sans lui ceci on parlait sport
n'aurait pas la même saveur c'est une
légende un grand monsieur du sport
francilien tout le monde l'adore
mesdames et messieurs coach Jean Miss ex
entraîneur du plaisir Rugby Club est
avec nous pendant une heure monsieur
Jean-Mi bonjour Miguel bonjour à tous et
à tous
comment allez-vous Jean
il fait beau sur la 4e oui alors vous
êtes officiellement vacances dans quoi
deux trois heures à peu près vous êtes
sur la route voilà donc faites attention
si vous êtes sur la route avec Jean il a
besoin d'arriver vite sur son lieu de
vacances
alors avant de passer au programme de
l'émission une fois n'est pas nous
allons parler de culture isme Muriel
bovilain originaire de mitainville dans
le sud des Yvelines à disputer le
championnat univers de culturisme en
juin à Séoul en Asie livelinoise a
remporté trois titres la première place
dans les catégories glamour un passage
sur scène en robe de soirée la première
place dans la catégorie transformation
et boutis sur la musculature des
fessiers une belle récompense pour la
sportive de plus de 50 ans qui fait du
culturisme seulement depuis quelques
années alors votre avis sur cette
performance j'imagine que
tout le monde est heureux de cette
performance autour de cette table
Philippe ouais c'est une belle
performance au bout de deux ans comme ça
c'est beau elle avait un objectif je
pense qu'elle avait beaucoup de kilos
avant et en deux ans plus ce qu'elle a
pris comme comme prix c'est pas mal je
veux dire
mais voilà
pas plus que ça mais voilà vous suivez
de loin
Audrey qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de
Muriel Beauvillain en fait au vu de son
histoire je crois que c'était elle était
malade il y a deux trois ans de ça elle
faisait plus de 100 kg donc c'est un
double mérite ne serait-ce que pour se
battre pour être en meilleure santé et
en plus dans le milieu féminin de faire
du culturisme j'ai envie de dire bravo
parce que le culte du corps en France
n'est pas celui de même à l'étranger
donc j'ai envie de dire chapeau bas à 50
ans donc bravo 50 ans c'est ça alors
grégoriez-vous qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez de Muriel je suis je suis du même
avis que
que les autres chroniqueurs je pense que
c'est une belle leçon de vie alors elle
a débuté aussi le culturisme la
musculation en hommage à son fils qui a
disparu en 2021 qui était un passionné
de musculation donc c'est aussi une
preuve que après une dépression après
aussi la maladie le sport ça peut aider
à se dépasser à aller mieux à se sentir
mieux dans ses baskets tout simplement
et aussi le la discipline qu'elle défend
le culturisme naturel ou on ne prend pas
de produit dopant tout se fait via la
musculation moi je crois que je pense
qu'il y a plus de mérite finalement à
pouvoir défendre cette discipline vous
avez pu assister surnaturel c'est tout
est naturel dans ce que fait à Muriel à
bauvillain Jean qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez vous de Muriel à Beauvillain et
c'est fantastique parce que
quand on sait les efforts c'est très
difficile le culturisme et la
musculation quand on sait les efforts
qu'il faut faire pour en arriver où on
est arrivé et moi je dis chapeau bas
parce que c'est des heures et des heures
et des heures d'abnégation et de travail
et il y a pas plus compliqué et plus
difficile que travailler la musculation
pure donc moi je dis bravo parce que en
plus on l'a dit à plus de 50 ans c'est
pas évident et faire ce qu'elle a fait
moi j'ai encore une fois je lui tire mon
chapeau franchement parce que c'est
vraiment des heures et des heures et des
jours de de combat d'entraînement et de
transpiration et des forts physiques qui
sont très très durs en musculation
autour de cette table qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce que je trouve qu'elle est
quand même pas disproportionnée
et tout là elle est elle est quand même
fine je suis sûr quand elle est en
pantalon et comme ça qu'on voit pas
qu'elle est que toi que c'est une toile
une culturiste et culturelisme aussi on
pense souvent plutôt culturisme masculin
Audrey qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez que ça soit que ça soit une
fille de se mettre dans cet objectif
en France surtout en plus ça a commencé
dans une 70 le culturisme mais c'est
vrai que à 50 ans et enfin dans le
milieu féminin c'est vrai qu'il faut le
dire il y a encore des regards des
préjugés il y a enfin vraiment je pense
qu'on peut dire il y a pas de tabou mais
j'ai envie de lui dire vraiment bras
parce que ça permet d'ouvrir aussi
d'autres portes pour d'autres femmes
c'est un exutoire peut-être un autre
sport qu'il faut peut-être féminiser la
mental aussi je pense qu'elle est déjà
aussi autour d'elle qu'il a qui
l'encourage et qu'il a qu'il la
maintienne donc
sceptique au début mais finalement
maintenant approuve totalement il
encourage avec des jeunes des sessions
déjà c'est la motivé
en tout cas elle va revenir à la
compétition fin 2024 avec d'autres
objectifs elle tentera de prendre encore
plus de muscles c'est son objectif à
nous la confier dernièrement sur le
plateau de TV 78 alors nous allons
maintenant passer au programme de
l'émission aujourd'hui nous allons
parler de basket livinois Victor web
banyama a folle à NBA depuis qu'il est
le premier choix de la draft il y aura
aussi un classement des meilleurs
sportifs yvelinois de la saison 2022
2023 Grégory vous allez nous donner vos
tops mais avant de parler de ces thèmes
on va parler à football
[Musique]
en football donc on connaît désormais le
successeur de Chris le FC Versailles a
annoncé ce samedi 1er juillet le nom de
son nouvel entraîneur principal il
s'agit de Laurent à Peyrelade l'ancien
joueur professionnel de Nantes du Mont
ou encore de Lille arrive après une
expérience de 7 ans au club de Rodez
avec cette équipe l'homme de 53 ans
réussi à faire monter le club avait René
de la Nationale 2 à la Nationale 1 puis
de la nationale une à la Ligue 2 le club
s'est ensuite maintenu en Ligue 2
pendant trois saisons avec un petit
budget la montée en Ligue 2 ce sera
justement l'un des objectifs de Laurent
Peyrelade pour y arriver il sera
accompagné au poste d'entraîneur adjoint
de Grégory Vignal qui a aussi une belle
carrière il est passé à parlant sous les
Glasgow Rangers les deux hommes ont
dirigé leur première séance
d'entraînement cette semaine la question
sur cette thématique est-il l'homme de
la situation pour le FC Versailles
oui ou non
oui pour tout le monde
pas de débat Philippe pourquoi pourquoi
bon on peut le dire
sa carrière de football professionnel et
aussi par rapport à son sa carrière
d'entraîneur même si elle est pas
elle est pas longue encore mais comme
fait 7 ans passée de régionale à Ligue 2
avec Rodez je pense que c'est pas mal
bon après on peut pas dire est-ce que ça
va être l'homme de la situation puisque
les entraîneurs c'est quand même souvent
la valse des entraîneurs on dit qu'il
est bon voilà on a des exemples concrets
mais je pense que c'est une bonne pioche
comme on dit voilà je pense que il a
fait du bon boulot il va continuer à
faire j'espère Jean qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez
oui je oui je rejoins un petit peu
Philippe
est-ce que c'est des notes je ne sais
pas rapport à Chris alors c'est
stratégie voilà je ne sais pas si c'est
vraiment l'homme de la situation puisque
ça c'est l'avenir qui nous le dira par
contre pour moi il rentre vraiment dans
le cadre de l'état d'esprit prix du club
de Versailles
c'était un esprit qui a été celui-là
depuis quelques années avec leur ancien
entraîneur qui a gravi aussi des
échelons juste pour arriver jusqu'à un
national et donc il rentre pour moi dans
cet état d'esprit par rapport à son
curriculum il a fait 7 ans à Rodez avec
lui aussi de CFA2 jusqu'à la Nationale 2
c'est ça
donc pour moi c'est quand même dans son
palmarès notamment son palmarès il
rentre un petit peu dans l'état d'esprit
que que refléter le club de de que vous
avez refaites comme de Versailles donc
pour moi je pense que c'est c'est quand
même dans la continuité de l'histoire du
club ça vous séduit plus qu'un crise qui
est un peu bling bling et bien pour moi
oui parce que justement le club avait
peut-être pas
n'était peut-être pas prêt à avoir ce
genre de d'entraîneur je pense parce que
je suis pas à l'intérieur du club mais
ça reflète le fait que c'est plus un
club un petit peu de famille de de avec
un bon état d'esprit avec des copains et
des des joueurs qui jouent ensemble et
qui mouillent le maillot ensemble et
dans cet état d'esprit un crise qui
malgré son son grand palmarès les
champions de France avec Lyon notamment
à l'époque mais je pense qu'il
correspondait pas à cet état d'esprit
alors que ce nouvel entraîneur lui a
plus a plus ce calque mieux cette état
d'esprit vous êtes satisfaite aussi de
la domination de cet entraîneur à Audrey
quand on voit donc je pense l'expérience
si tu as l'esprit moi j'ai juste une
petite note c'est qu'on hésite à voir un
défilé de d'entraîneur parce que ça peut
aussi avoir une décrivation sur l'ADN du
club donc je pense que apparemment de ce
que nous disent mes chers amis à mon
avis on va le voir assez longtemps on
espère en tout cas vous vous aimez bien
vous aimeriez qu'il s'engagent sur le
long terme à Versailles je pense que
c'est important pour dans l'équipe aussi
pour se projeter pour avoir aussi une
belle mentalité puis aussi même pour
l'équipe de se tenir vraiment un
entraîneur pour les voir grandir je
pense que c'est important
il apporte de la stabilité Grégory
stabilité ce qu'on peut dire c'est que
la stratégie elle est complètement
renversée pour Versailles effectivement
avant avec Youssef chibi on avait un
entraîneur historique qui avait fait
toutes les montées avec le club bon les
ennuis judiciaires le éloigné de
Versailles on est parti sur un profil de
crise qui avait pas une grosse
expérience en tant qu'entraîneur même
avec Le Mans il était pas très haut
placé dans le championnat de National
effectivement c'est un nom un nom
ronflant qui parlait aux amoureux de
foot mais plus pour son palmarès en
temps de footballeur et moi en tant
qu'entraîneur et là on part sur un
entraîneur vraiment qui a de
l'expérience expérience en plus des
petites divisions entre guillemets parce
que la nationale on commence déjà à
jouer dans dans le niveau expérience
aussi des montées il a réussi à faire
monter son groupe et on parle depuis
tout à l'heure de l'entraîneur moi je
pense qu'il faut mettre aussi en avant
son adjoint Grégory Vignal ils ont voulu
mettre en avant un duo cette année les
deux hommes se connaissent très bien le
FC Versailles parle d'une grande
complicité entre les deux et Grégory
Vignal ça va être son bras droit sur
l'aspect un peu plus jeune formation il
a une grosse expérience expérience du
côté des jeunes des Glasgow Rangers il a
été responsable de la préformation à
l'OM il entraîné les U23 de Dundee
également du côté du Royaume-Uni et je
pense que si on regarde un petit peu la
stratégie les premiers recrutements il y
a beaucoup de jeunes il y a aussi un
vivier à Versailles et je pense que ça
peut être intéressant on va dire cette
double casquette l'entraîneur qui a
l'expérience et son adjoint qui va
essayer de valoriser des jeunes et de
faire pourquoi pas monter aussi des
jeunes du centre de formation enfin du
centre de formation de la formation
Versailles vers l'équipe première je
pense que ça peut être intéressant aussi
juste pour un petit des chiffres à Rodez
il a un bilan de 98 victoires 69 nuls et
70 défaites il en est du coup le club en
Ligue 2 on l'a dit bilan plutôt correct
on peut le dire à un fil voilà correct
je trouve que c'est correct bon à part
la dernière demi-saison ou est-ce que
Rodez était 18e ou 19e c'est pour ça
qu'il a été évincé dommage mais c'est
toujours l'entraîneur qui trinque en
premier et voilà autrement je pense que
les défaites qu'il a sur son palmarès là
c'est surtout
cette saison en fin de compte c'est au
début bon voilà ils sont sauvés on sait
pour comment ils sont sauvés aussi de
Ligue 2 cette année avec ce qui s'est
passé à Bordeaux en plus le club donc
voilà
il y a aussi beaucoup de jeunes aussi
qui signent à Versailles cette saison
beaucoup de joueurs en entrée on a moins
de d'informations sur les joueurs qui
pourraient partir et quitter à
l'effectif mais c'est vrai qu'on regarde
le profil de joueur qui arrive le plus
vieux à 27 ans c'est la senadia Kaby qui
vient de Marty quatrième de national une
donc qui connaît bien aussi ce
championnat il y a Kevin Balla qui un
attaquant de 22 ans qui arrive en
provenance du pari FC il a quelques
matchs de Ligue 2 à son actif même si
jouer plutôt avec la réserve Kevin Najet
qu'un milieu de 22 ans en provenance de
Laval qui a été formé à Lens et Djibril
bamboura milieu offensive de 21 ans qui
ont prête énormément de talents il a
fait quelques bons en Ligue 1 avec Brest
où il a été formé il a été élu meilleur
genre de sa poule en National 2 du côté
de Chateaubriand et au-delà de ces
recrutements derrière en coulisses il y
a l'entraîneur qui travaille mais aussi
un nouveau responsable du recrutement
c'est Solomon cachala qui a fait du très
très bon travail cette année avec
Dunkerque Dunkerque qui monte de
national une à en Ligue 2 et il prend la
suite du coup de Michael Michael Michel
et donc c'est aussi une bonne recrue à
mon sens pour pour Versailles c'est un
homme qui a de l'expérience en terme de
recrutement dans cette division là on a
l'impression que ça se structure Audrey
ce club de Versailles c'est important
pour un club comme Versailles s'ils
veulent peut-être aller plus haut dans
le futur c'est très prometteur quand on
voit effectivement la liste des jeunes
on se projette énormément enfin je pense
que c'est assez solide
on aura peut-être encore peut-être plus
de sponsors peut-être aussi quand c'est
bien stabilisé quand effectivement
un chef d'équipe qui qu'il est qu'il est
projette c'est qu'il les emmène très
loin
c'est que positif en tout cas moi je
j'ai hâte de les suivre genre ça vous
plaît vous cette jeunesse qui arrive à
Versailles parce qu'on était quand même
l'année dernière sur des noms un petit
peu en ronflant enfin une carrière des
32 33 34 35 ans
là on voit ce sont des petits jeunes
finalement qui arrivent mais prometteurs
on est peut-être ce que je disais un
petit peu tout à l'heure on est
peut-être revenu sur une politique qui
était celle de Versailles avant
l'arrivée de Christ quoi ou quand on a
quand on a pris crise comme entraîneur
on est allé vous l'avez dit vous-même
cherchez des joueurs avec des puces des
noms avec des expériences ça peut
vieillissant qui ont permis d'avoir
quand même
une expérience quand même qui a permis
l'équipe emmené d'être
nationale parti du championnat ils
étaient premiers donc c'est c'était pas
mais maintenant je crois que pour aller
dans la durée et pour obtenir et pour
avoir l'objectif premier c'est celui de
monter en Ligue 2 je crois qu'on revient
un petit peu dans une politique de
jeunes de groupe et de de façonner un
groupe qui va qui va arriver à franchir
ce cap de la montée en Ligue 2 et non
pas sur des noms même si on pas besoin
aussi quand même de joueurs d'expérience
et de talent on en a besoin maintenant
Versailles encore une fois pour moi ils
mettent la carte il mise la carte des
jeunes et donc soit à volonté de voir
qui va rester de l'effectif de l'année
dernière et s'il peut y avoir un très
très bon mix entre des joueurs quand
même important qui ont une expérience
alors certes ils ont la trentaine bien
tassé mais ils ont quand même une
expérience du haut niveau mixer avec des
petits jeunes prometteurs faut voir
aussi si ça match les joueurs fiables la
sonate joue à Martigues il a 27 ans donc
on va dire en pleine force de l'âge et
il a joué énormément de matchs avec
Martigues donc il connaît cette division
aussi en plus qui est voilà pensionnaire
de National et qui est pas passé loin de
la montée cette année en Ligue 2 qui a
fini 4e effectivement alors on va
continuer à parler du FC Versailles le
FC Versailles dispose d'un tout nouveau
centre d'entraînement pour son groupe
national les joueurs vont s'entraîner
maintenant à Bougival sur l'île de la
loge le lieu était laissé libre par les
féminines du PSG
le site a des terrains de haut niveau
évidemment des salles de réunion pour
les analystes vidéo des espaces
conviviaux des salles de fitness et de
soins objectifs passer un nouveau palier
pour les matchs les joueurs de
Versailles devraient jouer au stade
Jean-Bouin à Paris comme l'année
dernière selon les dernières tendances
la question sur cette thématique le club
ne perd-il pas son identité en partant
notamment à Bougival oui ou non
sachant qu'ils seront à Bougival pour
l'entraînement et pour leur match à
jambon à Paris normalement vous êtes
partagé vous êtes tous partagés alors
pourquoi Philippe de plus leur identité
en allant jouer à j'envoie que Bougival
certes Bougival c'est je crois que c'est
à peu près à 20 km ou 20 minutes de
vingtaine voilà c'est ça mais ils sont
pas les c'est pas le seul club qui fait
ça je veux dire en région parisienne en
plus ça se fait ça se fait comment ça se
fait beaucoup machin si on regarde qui
ont PSG par rapport à Poissy qui
viennent et qui sont à Poissy le Stade
Français en rugby enfin voilà non je
pense pas en plus c'est des belles
installations je trouve que que ouais je
trouve que c'est bien c'est une nouvelle
entraîneur nouvelle enfin je trouve que
c'est top je pense que l'année dernière
ils sont ils ont pris comme on disait
tout à l'heure l'expérience parce que
comment il y en avait 6 à descendre et
cette année ils ont plus réfléchi et
et c'est en voyant les installations
c'est c'est bien c'est important Audrey
vous connaissez où pas le ce site de
ligue de la loge alors j'ai entendu
parler pour être honnête puisque c'est
pas très loin de Poissy après sur
l'identité je suis un peu partagé c'est
vrai que c'est une stratégie de
communication qu'il faut justement
peut-être cibler autrement ce qui est
important avant tout c'est les
équipements
sans équipement on peut pas forcément
bien travailler mais sur la sur
l'identité je pense que c'est une autre
manière de voir les choses donc
peut-être à détourner de manière de de
communiquer de peut-être valoriser
peut-être autre chose pour valoriser
cette cette équipe parce que
effectivement ils ont des belles
installations à Bougival mais il y a eu
quand même beaucoup de critiques sur les
réseaux sociaux notamment des supporters
un peu historiques qui ont un peu
titiller club en disant ok vous jouez
pas à domicile vous n'avez pas non plus
votre terrain d'entraînement à domicile
voilà par quelque chose Grégory le vrai
dossier éclaircir je suis d'accord avec
Philippe c'est le dossier du stade je
pense que tant que Versailles jouera à
l'extérieur de Versailles il y aura
effectivement une identité un petit peu
écornée ça je suis d'accord avec ça
maintenant
sur le site de Bougival moi je trouve ça
au contraire intéressant et je trouve
que au contraire c'est une bonne
nouvelle on a quand même l'impression
depuis qu'elle est nouveaux actionnaires
qui sont arrivés donc le nouvel
actionnaire avec son Mulliez et son son
bras droit Fabien Lazare qui est une
volonté de structurer le club et pour
structurer aussi un groupe qui a envie
de devenir professionnel dans l'avenir
il faut désinstallations de premier plan
il faut un Petit Campus comme le PSG
maintenant à son campus à Poissy il faut
que Versailles et son campus jusqu'à
présent les footballeurs de l'équipe
nationale s'entraîner à Porsche fontaine
ils partagaient les installations avec
les rugbyman donc peut-être que les
rugbyman et notre ami et notre ami
Pierre va va être content d'avoir un peu
plus de récupérer un peu plus ce
complexe de Porchefontaine mais moi je
pense que c'est important aussi de se
structurer et d'avoir un vrai campus
pour l'équipe première avec des
installation de premier plan qui était
occupé jusqu'à présent par par les
féminines du PSG mais au contraire je
trouve que c'est une bonne nouvelle dans
la volonté de structuration du club
Pierre Chevalier à qui on souhaite un
très bon anniversaire d'ailleurs genre
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez vous et
d'identité ou pas pour le FC Versailles
pour moi non pour moi non il n'y a pas
de perte d'identité parce que on perd
pour un club on perd son identité c'est
quand on ne joue pas à domicile quand on
ne fait pas les matchs à domicile donc
le terrain d'entraînement
au contraire là il est très belle
installations puis c'est très bien situé
je connais moi je le connais le
candidose parce qu'avant ça appartenait
l'idéologie
l'île de la loge je connais et donc
c'est très très belle installations et
pour moi je vais je vais dans le seuil
avec les féminines du PSG donc je vais
dans son sens parce que pour moi pour
une restructuration de clubs et une
stabilité d'asturostructuration et bien
c'est un bon un bel outil de travail là
où il pour une paire de identité et ça
c'est le gros problème qui est développé
sur autour de cette table depuis pas mal
de temps c'est leur stade leur stade et
leur match qui ne sont pas vraiment à
domicile ce qu'ils vont rejoindre encore
à Jean Bouin et j'envoie c'est pas leur
stade ça c'est sûr là il y a une
pertinité mais pas sur les entraînements
les entraînements ça ne peut apporter
qu'un plus au club et d'ailleurs on l'a
dit on la redit ici les les normes de
clubs qui ont alors leur terrain
d'entraînement ailleurs ça c'est pas ça
c'est pas un souci disponible à
Versailles bah il y en a pas beaucoup
justement et donc le le problème du
stade il va se le château
éventuellement
pour moi ce sera vraiment le le gros
dossier pour que vraiment le le club de
Versailles
puisse puisse travailler dans une dans
une belle lucidité c'est c'est ce
terrain c'est ce stade et cet endroit
pour jouer tant qu'ils auront pas réglé
ce problème là il y aura quand même un
petit un petit bémol et est-ce que ce
terrain entraînement va permettre à
l'équipe d'avoir vraiment de meilleurs
résultats à votre avis Philippe
ça contribue ça contribue quand même
quand tu es bien dans les installations
tout le monde tout le monde le lit quand
tu es bien quand tu si tu partages en
plus quand il fallait partager à
Fontaine c'est ça les installations avec
lui c'est si jamais facile les créneaux
les enfin si jamais facile là c'est ce
sera vraiment eux à eux et je trouve que
là tu peux faire du bon boulot je veux
dire non non c'est très bien je trouve
très bien Grégory ça va dans le sens de
l'identité de club justement d'avoir sur
un même campus les terrains
d'entraînement la salle de musculation
il y a une piscine ils vont pouvoir
peut-être se restaurer sur place
peut-être même faire des mises au vert
et dormir sur place ça va dans le sens
de l'identité de club donc finalement
quand on pose la question sur le terrain
d'entraînement moi je pense pas que ça
va briser l'identité de club bien au
contraire voilà puisqu'on parle de
centre d'entraînement et de performance
s'il y a un autre club qui va changer de
centre d'entraînement dans les prochains
jours c'est le Paris Saint-Germain qui
déménage du Camp des Loges de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye pour aller à
Poissy alors votre avis tout simplement
assez rapide sur ce complexe ultra
moderne qu'est-ce que vous en pensez je
crois qu'il est qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez à Audrey est-ce que vous avez des
poissons
c'est très bien très bien changement
enfin je trouve que au vu de ce qu'on
voit maintenant au niveau du nouveau
camp en fait c'est les entraînements
sont nettement mieux enfin on a vu les
cernes on a vu le film aussi
une espèce de convivialité pour les
joueurs et ils vont pouvoir se retrouver
jouer à la Playstation effectivement il
y a un baby-foot
le football c'est magnifique donc j'ai
envie de dire à 100% je suis très
contente pour eux genre qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez de ces
à Poissy c'est bien c'est très bien je
sais pas pourquoi
est-ce que c'était vraiment pas bien
est-ce que ça nécessitait vraiment un
changement bon je le disais mais moi je
n'ai pas la réponse mais de là si ça
peut éventuellement leur faire gagner la
Coupe de Ligue des Champions la Ligue
des Champions bah pourquoi pas on ira on
dirait qu'ils ont raison
on montre des photos là où il y a un
baby-foot et qui joue au football
on verra Grégory vous étiez vous il y a
quelques jours dans ce futur centre
d'entraînement du Paris-Saint-Germain
j'ai pu rentrer
ce bâtiment des joueurs qu'on a pu voir
en avant-première qui est un peu le
point central de site de 74 hectares il
y a quand même 17 terrains de de
football avec des technologies qui sont
produits par rapport au Parc des Princes
par exemple les terrains des pros sont
également chauffés bon je sais pas si ça
avec l'écologie ça c'est c'est moins sûr
en tout cas le bâtiment moi ce qui m'a
marqué j'ai trouvé que c'était vraiment
voilà fait pour pour la performance on
n'est pas dans le luxe non plus les
chambres sont très belles mais c'est pas
des chambres de luxe voilà on a pas non
plus on n'est pas dans un hôtel je
trouve 5 étoiles mais c'est standard
après bon l'espace de balnéothérapie la
salle de musculation très très belle
aussi et effectivement pendant la visite
on a bien insisté sur les espaces de vie
commune au-delà des chambres donc il y a
un espace avec un baby-foot où on va
pouvoir jouer je disais aux consoles de
jeux vidéo il y a un endroit avec un
billard il y a des salles de réunion
c'est vrai que du côté de la direction
du Paris Saint-Germain on a insisté sur
ces moments d'échange quand il y aura
des mises au vert pour pour les joueurs
de pouvoir leur garantir des moments
d'échange entre eux pour construire
peut-être un peu plus de cohésion de
groupe parce que c'est peut-être aussi
ce qui manque aujourd'hui à cette équipe
parisienne en tout cas on souhaite bon
courage à Versailles au PSG pour la
saison prochaine et surtout une bonne
installation sur leur nouveau centre
d'entraînement alors on va maintenant
vous parler basket les San Antonio Spurs
sont annoncés que Victor webanyama avait
signé son contrat après avoir été drafté
en première position de la draft le 23
juin dernier à une première pour un
basketteur français le joueur de 19 ans
originaire du généreux concours va
toucher environ 55 millions de dollars
sur 4 ans sous réserve que les Spurs
activent une option pour le conserver
sur les deux dernières années votre avis
déjà sur ce gros chèque Victor
webmaniema va toucher c'est à peu près
les standards d'un numéro un draft
c'est tout à fait logique tout est
logique mais c'est vraiment la la base
c'est de la folie c'est vraiment de la
de la justement
vous me permettez de faire la transition
en tout cas c'est la folie aux
États-Unis depuis sa signature on a vu
des tags à son effigie à son Antonio les
supporters l'ont accueilli comme une
rockstar la draft a été la plus suivie
de l'histoire de la NBA avec 128
millions de connexions une véritable
webmania alors vous comprenez cette
folie autour de Victor et benyama Audrey
pour garçon qui a 19 ans de mettre 21
c'est ça
les différents sources alors pour être
précis apparemment
on mesure avec les chaussures c'est pour
ça qu'il fait 2 mètres 25
apparemment il aurait des chaussures un
peu ouais
ça permet après de créer une légende un
peu autour des joueurs un peu plus grand
que que
normalement ça taille réelle c'est de
mettre 21 2m2 voilà là 2 m 25 voire même
certains sites
un peu plus de 5 ans
557 c'est 22 cm de plus des joueurs
après oui je la comprends cette folie on
parle de de basket on parle d'un sport
parmi les plus suivis aux États-Unis on
est dans une autre dimension là on passe
de la bête clique élite à la NBA c'est
pas du tout la même chose c'est même pas
le même sport pour moi qu'est-ce que
vous en pensez Philippe
j'ai hâte de voir déjà ce soir parce que
dans cette nuit je dirige
son premier match contre Hornet dans la
sommaire quand les arrête j'ai hâte déjà
de voir le premier mal même si peut-être
qu'il va pas jouer beaucoup mais
je crois pas beaucoup mais j'ai hâte que
ça commence de le voir je le dis depuis
qu'on en parle sur le plateau mais j'ai
vraiment hâte de voir et là il est en
train de prendre en plus en musculature
il est à fond il s'entraîne du très dur
très dur récemment moi je l'ai vu pour
pas citer au Parc des Princes donc c'est
vrai c'est impressionnant de mettre 22
23 24
c'est le fils c'est lui qui me l'a pris
parce que je sais pas comment faire je
sais pas comment on fait il dit j'ai
l'habitude
alors mais qui dit médiatisation dit
souvent aussi des tracteurs ouais
maniyama était gentiment chambré regardé
après sa première séance de shoot dans
la salle des Spurs devant les
photographes ou MBA en effet raté
beaucoup de cire et les fans les fans
des Rockets de Houston ainsi que
d'autres sueurs de la NBA l'internaute
c'est même interrogé pour savoir s'il
est Spurs avaient choisi le bon joueur
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez Jean voilà
il marque là par contre
on verra bon on va pas juger ce joueur
sur trois paniers en exercice comme ça
raté
c'est c'est le bon de bonne guerre c'est
c'est pas
méchants peut-être avoir ou Emmanuel ma
dans leur équipe de petits points de
jalousie aussi certainement après c'est
quand même le phénomène franchement je
crois que tout le monde l'attend tout le
monde attend il va falloir pour moi il
va il y a deux choses pour moi il va
falloir que ce soit très très fort
mentalement parce que là bon on parlait
on le faisait que parler de lui mais
c'était voilà c'était c'était peut-être
peut-être là maintenant ça y est il est
deux pieds dedans et là il va falloir
maintenant qu'il prouve sportivement
qu'il est vraiment l'homme de la
situation
le le grand espoir du du basket mondial
que tout donne tout le monde parle donc
ça il va falloir qu'il soit très très
très fort dans sa tête parce que là ça
va pas être facile c'est pas du tout le
même challenge qu'il a pu avoir jusqu'à
maintenant et deuxièmement le le gros
problème de tout sportif c'est la
blessure donc il faut lui souhaiter
qu'il ne se blesse pas je crois que
comme Philippe dit qu'il fait beaucoup
de préparation physique notamment de la
musculation je crois que surtout dans le
championnat de la NBA ou c'est un petit
peu plus musclé au niveau des rapports
physiques comme France donc il va avoir
besoin de s'épaissir un petit peu et de
d'être un petit peu plus guerrier et
pour moi 90 matchs par saison donc
c'est c'est deux ces deux principes pour
le pour moi ce sera vraiment les points
de l'honneur qui fera qui mettent pour
pour être le grand joueur que tout le
monde attend Audrey il faut peut-être
qu'il se mette un peu dans sa bulle à
votre avis ouais benyama qui parle
peut-être avec tes anciens aussi qui
sont passés par les Spurs San Antonio
alors je pourrais pas forcément dire
autant que que mes amis mais c'est vrai
que même tenue par cœur a dit si il ne
se blesse pas ça sera un des plus grands
joueurs de l'histoire donc c'est vrai
que quand même qu'on s'y tenue de 10
c'est que c'est la vérité après c'est
vrai que je pense qu'on va voir la photo
qui va s'afficher à l'écran ils ont
mangé ensemble pour le lui a donné
quelques petits conseils mais c'est
important aussi d'avoir aussi un soutien
comme comme Tony après c'est vrai que
SATA et c'est à la fois on a tout mais
aussi comme le disait effectivement Jean
et Philippe il faut effectivement
muscler les articulations pour pour être
aussi performante dans le temps dans sa
bulle oui parce qu'il est médias vont
aussi un peu jalouser vont un petit peu
le titiller mais aujourd'hui voilà le
basket ça fait d'air il faut aussi le
rappeler et c'est vraiment que c'est
pour moi c'est une révélation enfin je
pense que Philippe peut le confirmer oui
qui reste concentrer sur ces matchs
voilà vous y croyez
en tout cas on va espérer si Tony le dit
moi je j'y crois
ce matin Sean Elliot dit que web banama
lui a demandé la première chose qu'il
lui a demandé donc les gens de NBA
comment on fait pour bien se reposer
entre deux matchs donc c'est déjà qu'il
est dans dans quoi dans la traite de ce
bip bien gérer parce que ça va être très
compliqué on sait que c'est un jour qui
se blessait souvent avant qu'il arrive
au mètre 92 cette saison il a réussi à
être plutôt régulier à jouer quasiment
l'ensemble des matchs donc ça va être
vraiment un paramètre à prendre en
compte qu'il a demandé ça
schenelliottes
pas plus que ça pour les paniers on a vu
il fait le parallèle avec le foot des
joueurs de foot présentant en grande
pompe notamment au Barça qui ratait des
jongs devant le public et au final ça ça
va pas empêcher que ce soit des grands
joueurs derrière alors on va écouter un
dernier mot sur weba bah écoutez une
musique je sais pas si ça vous parle
est-ce qu'on peut l'entendre
alors vous allez le dire pourquoi
pourquoi cette musique est bien par
rapport à un incident improbable entre
weba nyama et Britney Spears Britney
aurait pris une gifle de la part de la
sécurité des Spurs en tentant de prendre
une photo avec la nouvelle star des
Spurs à Las Vegas elle a tapé sur
l'épaule et ça a énervé le service de
sécurité lui ne l'a pas vu parce qu'il
marchait tout droit la chanteuse a des
posé une main courante pour coup et
blessures alors vous en pensez quoi de
cette histoire c'est un petit peu ça
aussi la folie de la NBA c'est normal
c'est tout à fait logique donc non mais
voilà il est vraiment c'est là qu'on
voit qu'il est suivi partout et chaque
geste qui va faire au chèque voilà il y
aura toujours quelque chose donc c'est
et c'est normal je veux dire c'est voilà
c'est la sécurité de Wemba miama qui a
pas reconnu abritée s'exprimer
publiquement là justement pendant la
serveur ligue pour dire ben désolé je
l'ai je ne l'ai pas vu je marchais tout
droit c'était prévu que je m'arrête pas
faut pas avoir d'attroupement quelqu'un
m'a touché je savais même pas qui
c'était
il y a un service de sécurité qui est
mis en place autour de lui pour le
protéger donc pas parce que elle
s'appelle Britney Spears
de dimension qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez cette histoire Audrey je pense
que c'est pas la première ce sera pas la
dernière à mon avis ça attise aussi les
convoitises Britney Spears elle a bien
raison de le faire pour parler d'elle
c'est comme ça ça marche maintenant puis
il y a de buzz et mieux c'est tout genre
parce que je voulais poster une photo
sur les réseaux sociaux avec lui et
apparemment ça s'est mal passé un
Grégory c'est mal passé bon après s'il y
a vraiment eu claque c'est peut-être je
sais pas faudra que le service de la
sécurité en tout cas c'est vrai que
maintenant dès qu'il va se passer
quelque chose puis il le disait on va on
va parler de web benyama finalement
c'est pas Wayne banyama directement
c'est son service de sécurité lui il
s'est rendu compte de rien dans cette
histoire mais il se retrouve autour de
la polémique
ça lui change peut-être un peu de la
France et je pense que voilà ils
disaient il y a quelques années que
c'est Britney Spears qui lui court après
le contraire voilà je pense qu'il est
pas cru même si je pense qu'il est un
peu jeune quand Britney Spears avait
beaucoup de je pense quand même je crois
pas qu'il était né lors des premiers euh
de Britney Spears on vérifiera après
l'émission alors on passe maintenant à
notre page débat
[Musique]
on va maintenant parler des Jeux
olympiques de 2024 elles seront 8
communes des Yvelines ont été
sélectionnées pour accueillir la flamme
olympique sur leur territoire le mardi
23 juillet à 2024 la femme la flamme
traversera les communes de
Mantes-la-Ville de Poissy de
Saint-Germain-en-Laye de Rambouillet
pour pour des segments de 3 à 5 km
Saint-Rémy-lès-Chevreuse Les Mureaux et
Guyancourt au golf national pour les
segments d'un kilomètre le soir les
célébrations se dérouleront au domaine
de Madame Elisabeth après un parcours
dans les rues de Versailles au total 100
personnes seront choisies pour porter la
flamme olympique sur environ 200 mètres
chacun alors la question sur cette
thématique ce rendez-vous sera-t-il un
grand événement festif et populaire
forcément dans les Yvelines le 23
juillet 2024
Jean pourquoi
quand même
la flamme olympique c'est quand un
événement sportif mondial planétaire
donc c'est quand même non seulement
fantastique mais en plus c'est un
honneur pour les personnes qui vont être
choisies de de porter cette flamme
olympique je crois que on n'a pas de
chiffre mais il doit y avoir quand même
énormément de gens
dont 1000 pour les Jeux paralympiques
mais là sur la portion qui va être
les gens qui vont être choisis c'est un
honneur immense une centaine de
personnes à peu près ces gens qui vont
avoir la chance de porter cette flamme
olympique qui est quand même tout un
symbole et pour moi le symbole du sport
dans tous ces états et donc forcément
c'est un événement fantastique et qu'on
ne vivra qu'une fois dans notre vie donc
forcément en plus dans les Yvelines donc
c'est fantastique la flamme passera
aussi au je suis très contente parce
qu'au vu de la situation cette société
qui est un petit peu fracturée
excusez-moi c'est un peu poétique mais
je trouve ça il va enfin un moment
vraiment important un contexte le sport
rassemble comme l'a dit d'ailleurs
pierre Bédié c'est un vecteur de
rassemblement le président des Yvelines
et le fait de pouvoir aussi ne serait-ce
que apprécié je suis très contente et
tant pis à caisse de pouvoir valoriser
le patrimoine de cette belle ville c'est
aussi de pouvoir découvrir d'autres
communes sur sur leur force aussi parce
qu'on les découvre pas forcément tous
les jours et je trouve que voilà c'est
comme tu dis genre c'est un moment fort
c'est le sport mais ça dit beaucoup de
choses des jeunes qui sont effectivement
avec du handicap sans handicap c'est
tout le monde est là tout le monde est
ensemble pour porter cette flamme qui a
une belle symbolique vous aimeriez la
porter Philippe
mais c'est possible que je la porte on
verra ça dans quelques semaines
par rapport à Orange je veux dire on m'a
on m'a comment je veux dire proposer
voilà c'est ça donc voilà non non c'est
un honneur et puis quand on voit la
flamme dans tous ces bons après c'est
super bien bon après je suis juste déçu
qu'il y a des polémiques parce que voilà
par rapport à certaines villes pas
certaines villes mais ce sera toujours
comme ça de toute façon même quand il y
a des grandes compétitions
quand même et puis même si c'est que 200
m par voilà c'est quand même c'est un
honneur c'est beau c'est il y aura la
sécurité tout autour non mais c'est vrai
que c'est c'est fantastique
pour moi la flamme
si vous voulez du symbole de l'olympisme
c'est le symbole du sport par excellence
c'est vraiment ce serait un rêve et
effectivement toutes les communes ne
peuvent pas être garnies et ne peut pas
être traversé par la flamme mais là si
on regarde le parcours un peu on va dire
les quatre points cardinaux de des
Yvelines quasiment en tout cas on a de
la Vallée de Chevreuse du nord des
Yvelines Poissy Saint-Germain-en-Laye
aussi la région de Versailles 50 ans en
Yvelines donc j'ai envie de dire les
Illinois sont plutôt garnis et en plus
c'est tombé quasiment à quelques jours
d'intérêt d'une autre bonne nouvelle on
a appris on le savait c'était dans les
cartons que le parcours aussi du de
l'épreuve de cyclisme sur route
passerait largement dans les Yvelines
avec un passage une boucle sur la plaine
de Versailles passage dans la vallée de
Chevreuse donc on multiplie les bonnes
nouvelles et ça confirme que les illumes
auront une place de choix pour ces Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 il y a aussi
des célébrités qui vont porter à la
flamme je pense notamment au trappiste
Jamel Debbouze qui pourrait porter la
flamme on ne sait pas s'il portera la
flamme dans les Yvelines ou dans un
autre département mais bon il serait
plus logique qu'il veut la porte
peut-être dans les Yvel il portera la
flamme comme d'autres personnalités dont
Thomas Pesquet qu'est-ce que vous en
pensez ou je suis autour de cette table
un trappiste Jamel Debbouze des
célébrités voilà qui qui porteront la
flamme c'est bien qu'il y a un peu de
j'ai envie de dire de tous les tous les
profils des anonymes et aussi des
célébrités pour Djamel oui c'est c'est
une reconnaissance supplémentaire pour
pour le parcours de ce jeune trappiste
qui qui aujourd'hui est monté très haut
Grégory il faut qu'il y ait une
vladiversité enfin connu pas connu qu'on
soit vraiment tous une vraie mixité une
vraie diversité c'est ça la flamme
olympique
je reste je reste sur le sport je reste
vraiment sur le sport pour moi je l'ai
dit tout à l'heure pour moi c'est c'est
vraiment le symbole même du sport et il
y a tellement de sportifs donc tout le
monde loin de là sera
aura la chance de pouvoir le faire donc
je pense ils vont pas tout mélanger
parce que justement je vois pas pourquoi
cette flamme olympique serait utilisé
pour valoriser d'autres personnes c'est
le sport vous êtes plus sur l'espace moi
je suis vraiment pour les sportifs voilà
et pour moi cette flamme de
sportifs que ce soit des anciennes des
jeunes des on a que l'embarras du choix
je crois qu'il faut pas mélanger c'est
l'emblème du sport mondial donc il faut
que ça reste sur le terrain du sport et
ne pas ouvrir d'autres polémiques
inutiles en ce moment
pour chaque sport qu'il y a comment aux
Jeux Olympiques des jeunes qui font de
chaque discipline il y en a assez tout
je trouve que ce serait plus symbolique
que des voilà des anciens sportifs aussi
ça il y a pas de souci mais
le showbiz voilà je crois qu'il a pas la
pause
alors maintenant passer à l'envoler de
Grégory à chaque fois ça a été un moment
très fort dans la dans la saison et dans
cette émission il y a eu beaucoup de de
rire parfois des larmes parfois des
coups de cœur de quoi allez-vous nous
parler aujourd'hui Grégory je vais faire
le bilan calmement en me remémorant
chaque instant de cette saison il s'est
passé il s'en est passé des événements
et des performances sportives l'heure de
se poser une question qui est le sportif
de 2022 2023 voici une petite sélection
lui trust régulièrement sa place dans
nos sportifs de l'année depuis quelques
mois Arthur rinderknech 27 ans encore
fait parler son talent pour la première
fois de sa carrière le tennisman
saint-germain-nois c'est tissé au
deuxième tour de Roland-Garros si les
cartes Gasquet devant un cours Suzanne
Lenglen survolté et Titi au deuxième
tour pendant une bonne partie du match
le numéro 9 mondial Taylor Fritz
quelques semaines plus tard au tournoi
du Queens rinderknech s'offre même le
luxe de prendre un set au numéro 1
mondial Carlos Alcaraz oui mais voilà là
cette semaine le 92ème joueur au
classement ATP a été éliminé dès le
premier tour de Wimbledon par son
compatriote Alexandre Muller une défaite
qui lui est fatal pour être notre numéro
1 de cette saison oui si je parle bien
de la saison 2022 2023 alors même si au
tennis la saison est calqué sur l'année
civile j'ai pris en compte les faits
d'armes réalisés également depuis août
dernier et puisqu'on parle de tennis il
y a un événement marquant pour le sport
français la victoire au Masters de
Caroline Garcia la saint germanoise de
29 ans n'a fait qu'une bouchée en finale
de sabalenka c'était en novembre dernier
aux États-Unis la deuxième fois
seulement qu'une Française remporte la
compétition et 17 ans après le sacre
d'Amélie Mauresmo en 2005 à l'instar
d'Arthur indarkness carro Garcia brille
moins cette saison cette année elle sort
des le deuxième tour de Roland-Garros
elle a fait un huitième de finale il
faut aussi le préciser du côté de
l'Australian Open reste à savoir son
parcours à Wimbledon la joueuse affronte
Cathy volinette au troisième tour c'est
la pépite du sport automobile français a
seulement 14 ans Jimmy Ellias est devenu
le premier pilote numéro 1 de
l'international karting ranking dans la
catégorie reine c'est un classement qui
a été donc mis en place cette année par
la FIA la catégorie ça s'appelle ok
celui qui a passé ses premières années
de vie à Guyancourt doit batailler avec
des pilotes parfois plus
âgés et professionnel donc plus âgé et
professionnel tout cela pour décrocher
un volant dans une écurie de Formule 4
et pourquoi pas dès la saison prochaine
après un début de saison canon le pilote
de wordre Racing est rentré dans le rang
étant l'actuel numéro 15 mondial mais le
protéger d'Estéban Ocon en garde un peu
encore peut-être sous la pour
poursuivre son rêve concourir à un jour
en Formule 1 va-t-il fouler encore
longtemps la pelouse alors il a pas
encore foulé mais va-t-il la foulée
pendant longtemps la pelouse et terrain
flambant neuf du campus PSG à Poissy
l'avenir de Kylian Mbappe semble de plus
en plus s'écrire en pointillé au Paris
Saint-Germain ou Kylian Saint-Germain
appelez-le comme vous voulez un tant il
a été encore primordial dans la conquête
du 11e titre de champion de France de
son club cette saison c'est son seul
titre il faut le préciser avec le
Trophée des champions c'est statistiques
43 matchs tu te compétition confondues
41 du marqués et 9 passes décisives et
on se souviendra sur toutes ces
performances en bleu lui qui a inscrit
un triplé en finale de la Coupe du monde
rien que ça le gamin de Bondy qui fêtera
ses 25 ans décembre n'est pas fait du
même bois que les autres plus on avance
plus on monte en gamme là je vais vous
parler à mon sens de l'émotion de cette
saison il faut remonter à octobre
dernier du côté du vélo de Rome national
de 50 ans en Yvelines se tenait les
Championnats du monde de cyclisme sur
piste enfin enfin mathildegro est sur le
toit du monde l'athlète a décroché à 23
ans la médaille d'or en vitesse
individuelle une demi-finale empocher au
caractère et au terme d'un suspense
insoutenable face à l'Allemande in the
avant de terras en finale une autre
allemande Friedrich la communion était
incroyable avec son public 50 chinois
venu en nombre dans les gradins et on
est un patient bien sûr de voir les JO
qui se dérouleront bien sûr toujours au
Vélodrome national de
Saint-Quentin-en-Yvelines et puis
comment ne pas terminer par lui son nom
désormais tout le monde le connaît
Victor when banyama 19 ans vient de
faire le grand saut partir en NBA le
prestigieux championnat de basket
nord-américain choix numéro 1 de la
draft recruté par les Spurs de San
Antonio il marche un peu plus dans les
pas de Tony Parker illustre français de
la franchise texane avec ses quatre ses
quatre titres en NBA on a déjà de voir
les débuts du petit de l'Entente le
chêne et Versailles enfin du psy du très
grand du géant de maître 21 de 1m25
selon selon les différents médias le
buzz actuel autour de Wendy de mettre 21
on va rester sur 2m21 mais le buzz
actuel ne doit pas faire oublier ça
saison exceptionnelle réalisée du côté
des Metz 92 de Boulogne Levallois qui a
été finaliste et de la bête clic Elite
une moyenne de 21,6 points 10,4 bombes
2,4 passe et 3 contre un tel rendement
il fallait le récompenser Wayne banyama
hérité des trophées de MVP meilleur
marqueur meilleur compteur meilleur
défenseur et meilleurs jeunes de la
saison du championnat de France de LNB
rien que ça voilà sur sa cheminée
je suis quand même pour quelques bagues
NBA
c'est plus petit vous l'avez compris que
du beau monde bah il ne vous reste plus
les amis qu'à faire votre choix du
sportif de la musique de l'année Grégory
pour vous du coup ça sera Victor Hugo
Audrey je vais rester dans la parité
donc pour Mathilde gros Mathilde
du monde Philippe
autrement
Mbappé si il avait gagné la coupe non
s'il avait gagné la Coupe du Monde et si
la fin de saison n'aura pas été
tumultueuse avec lui voilà c'est
autrement mais voilà
mais bon Victor
Hugo
pour moi oui parce que c'est c'est le
phénomène de l'année et pour moi après
finalement il n'a pas gagné pour
l'instant non vraiment
Mathilde de gros qui a remporté quand
même une médaille dans des champions
parce que c'est un titre qu'elle a
obtenu j'hésitant tous les deux pour
tout vous dire et j'ai hésité
mais pour moi
c'est vraiment
un sportif français puis j'ai réagi en
français si on met la charrue avant les
bugs donc
il a il a pas encore prouvé un NBA m'ont
dit des gens que c'est un grand champion
donc pour moi c'est quand même voilà pas
beaucoup donc on en a un pour moi c'est
incontestablement le meilleur le sportif
de l'année c'est sportif de l'année je
reste sur ce que j'ai dit l'émotion de
l'année à mon sens c'est quand même
Mathilde de gros la médaille d'or mais
si voilà il faut distinguer l'émotion du
et du sportif voilà en tout cas les deux
points un bon point pour le sportif à
Victor et maniyama et l'émotion moi on
l'a vécu d'ailleurs on était au
Vélodrome tous les deux Mickaël à ce
moment-là c'était une ambiance
incroyable c'est pour ça que moi je
m'étais penché plus sur mes types de
gros moi personnellement mais bon après
c'est vrai
à l'avenir devant lui et l'avenir
s'annoncera Dieu c'est le phénomène quoi
c'est vraiment le phénomène c'est ça
alors de parler de yoga Vinyasa dans
cette dernière partie malheureusement
l'émission touche bientôt à sa fin on en
reparlera à la rentrée ses premiers
toute la saison on l'avait dans les
cartons malheureusement on n'a pas pu en
parler je sais qu'Audrey vous êtes très
déçu
de longs mois qu'on en parle pas le
choix dans la date pour parler
malheureusement
mais par contre pour me faire pardonner
je vous propose un best of des meilleurs
moments de la saison sur ce plateau de
si on parlait sport on regarde tout de
suite le best of et on revient ici juste
après
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans si on
parlait sport c'est le premier numéro de
cette saison sur TV 78 c'est notre
cerise sur le gâteau notre flamme
olympique comment allez-vous Jean à tous
bonne soirée
ne serait-ce que prendre 10 kilos
pendant l'hiver je trouve ça un peu
hallucinant mais mais après
bon
apparemment
toujours et donc
à quel moment pourra dire que le FC
Versailles est un prétendant sérieux
pour une montée
j'ai tout regardé et limite en léger
différé léger différé en live mais bon
quand on n'a pas le choix dans la date
on s'adapte
puis lors du quart de finale face à
l'Italie Grégory
on va on va donner la parole aux
spécialistes
par contre un Mike un grand fan du
football italien notre italienne lover
notre tour de Pise Grégory canal est
avec nous pendant une heure de Pise
qu'elle va rester en place un petit Père
Noël hein c'est ça sur votre veste le
Père Noël de circonstances sur un gros
Père Noël
plutôt à tout à l'heure de révision je
sais que vous avez parfaitement révisé
l'émission C'est ça sur le bout des
doigts sur le bout des doigts et surtout
dans vos spams
ça sera pas dit à l'antenne je sais
qu'au niveau des calendriers au niveau
du choix dans la date c'est difficile
pour la FFF de décaler les matchs un
petit duel entre Jean et Pierre allez
votre Jean-Pierre parce que pour te
faire chier alors
Matteo voilà Matteo je les vois je les
vois tous les dimanches tous les samedis
tout le temps tout le temps sur les
routes des Yvelines et donc c'est une
terre de vélo
déjà je plaisante
donc il est jeune Audrey on le met pas
dans les flops ils sont jeunes tous les
deux
les Templiers ils ont quand même
quelques pom-pom girls cheerleaders
maintenant je crois je crois qu'on dit
ça
le pays la France a une équipe de une
comme un pays de on dirait pas mais bon
voilà il a quand même dit plus tout ce
qu'il a
été précisé
les règles pour moi
le sportif de l'année
pour deux raisons la première parce que
je m'étais promis de pouvoir prononcer
donc je l'ai fait ça a marché Victor
on peut dire wembia apparemment aussi
est-ce que vous l'avez encore plus
maintenant genre
fabuleux c'était bien
l'équipe on va dire cette année
donc je suis un peu timide mais en tout
cas je suis très contente de voir les
pépites en puissance en tout cas au fur
et à mesure des émissions que ce soit
vous Audrey ou vous Philippe Grégory
c'est un petit mot peut-être c'est ma
troisième saison euh c'est toujours un
plaisir de pouvoir parler de ce qui nous
anime avec avec les gens bien sûr et
gauche du salon
à bientôt sur TV 78 et surtout bel été
[Musique]